A couple of weeks ago, we uploaded a video
all about microbes in slow motion, but here’s
the thing about recording in slow motion,
when you record for a minute, you end up with
way more than a minute of video, because it
is in slow motion.
So you end up with a lot more footage than
you need for an average episode of Journey
to the Microcosmos.
And this week, we’re taking a break from
our normal uploads in order to give our team
some time to relax during the holiday break,
but we also wanted to give you a chance to
sit back, relax, take a break from whatever’s
going on, and enjoy all of the uncut footage
from our slow motion video.
Now, if you’re looking for more information
about the clips in this video, be sure to
go back and check out our Microbes in Slow
Motion video because today, we’ll only be
featuring our Master of Microscopes James
Weiss’s beautiful images and Andrew Huang’s
fantastic music and I am going to stop talking
and let you enjoy those in just a second.
But before I go, I should mention that if
you do enjoy this type of thing, we upload
an hour long video like this every month for
our patrons over at Patreon.com/journeytomicro.
Alright, that’s all, enjoy!